I'm sweating like a sinner in church
right now I'm gonna tell you that oh
that's one thing yeah today we're gonna
be trying a real pilgrim food I'm not
excited it's gonna be great
I don't really know anything about the
pilgrims in my head have you seen the
village they kind of it like that
they've landed in Massachusetts right
Virginia
no they kind of destroyed everything
that matters
pilgrim food equals probably disgusting
so we'll see here we go stew that
doesn't sound American y'all at all Oh
real pull me off
it looks like spaghetti squash and it
smells like ass good don't wanna add a
texture it's not as bad as I thought I
actually do genuinely think that wasn't
so bad
[Music]
I'm surprised I think I'm kind of
impressed with them actually I literally
didn't have lunch in it like I'm going
to continue eating this you don't need
it back Sam that's not a name of a thing
I don't really like the smell of this
one it was like a wet corn muffin okay
this is good
I don't know if you can see this but
it's not moving so oh wow it's I'm
really like stay in there there go oh
now I'm gonna man down for the month I
don't know if I'd eat it again but I
don't hate it
how did you guess Oh pancakes
okay I'm stoked I'm kind of interested
in oh I'm really excited
oh god oh you ruined it hmm I didn't
believe they had icing sugar once you
realize or like accept the fact that
it's not pancake it's like let's eat
this yeah I really wasn't mad at this at
all like good job
pilgrims definitely not mad at no
emotions like towards that I can't stop
you know these people
it wasn't anything to tread that was all
completely fine
way more mush than I was expecting very
very mushy but not as nasty as I thought
it was gonna be pilgrims are boring and
their food is boring I don't think I
would survive as a pilgrim
I need technology way too much for that
I'm also scared of animals as well
2017 over 16 17 same with the Caribbean
yeah that was slaves Oh dark history
every part of
[Music]